good evening everybody and welcome to
this evening's virtual meeting of
stratford's unhaven district's
planning committee my name is council
peter richards and i will be chairing
the meeting this evening we are fast
approaching six o'clock on
the 3rd of february 2021 and along with
the rest of the uk we will be
showing our remembrance and thanks to
captains to tom moore for one minute
so if we could please just take one
minute in remembrance
and then we will start the meeting
proper thanks
members officers thank you very much
that is one minute i appreciate
you taking the time to do that and
members of public thank you for your
patience as well
okay before we start um some uh
housekeeping to run through
very quickly just a quick note uh as a
reminder as much as anything that this
meeting is being
live streamed and recorded for
publication on both council's website
and on youtube members you have been
provided with a
code of etiquette for these virtual
meetings in advance of tonight's meeting
just to reiterate a few of the salient
points
please can you make sure your device is
either charged or
charging please can you remember to mute
your microphones when you are not
speaking of course you will need to
remember to
unmute them when you are speaking uh if
you would like to speak
p please indicate you wish to do so in
the chat bar and i will call upon you to
do so at the appropriate
time if you have any other devices as
well uh alongside you if you could
please turn them
to silent uh so we don't get disturbed
by them that would be greatly
appreciated
if for any reason you encounter any i.t
issues causing you to drop out of the
meeting at any given time
uh please make best endeavors to rejoin
us
you will have been deemed to have left
the meeting at the point of which you
lose connection
uh should you not be able to rejoin and
we will continue provided we remain
corrupt there are two numbers uh in our
meeting chat should you have any
technical issues please do call those
and we will get you back in as soon as
possible um to confirm uh checks have
been made to ensure that all members of
the committee are in attendance
and they have confirmed in the presence
of the council's legal officer
that they can see and hear proceedings
and have read all of the appropriate
documents
we also have a number of officers online
with us tonight so first of all from
uh democratic services we have um banks
from our legal
uh services uh we have mina mac our
solicitor
and from planning in no particular order
we have aaron welleston
ronnie heath louise casey and sarah
mcpherson and our planning manager this
evening is richard gardner
richard do you have a statement you'd
like to make at this point yes thank you
mr chairman
um just to say that my role tonight is
to provide impartial advice
and to assist members in their decision
taking thank you
fabulous thank you very much okay for
public speakers if i could please
ask all members of the public who have
registered to speak that when you do
dial in and join us if you could please
follow on
along the meeting on your phones and to
mute
or turn off any live streams the live
stream is slightly delayed and it does
cause some issues in terms of us hearing
and understanding what you're trying to
say so please if you could do that
uh when you speak that would be great
you will also need to press star and
six to unmute yourself but i will remind
you of that at the given time
right let's dive in item number one is
apologies
and do we have any apologies please yes
chairman we've got apologies from
councillors adam
crump and henshaw seraphim fabulous
thank you very much
and disclosures of interests please
members please indicate in the chat if
you have any
and i do have one for
all of us and you'll have to bear with
me when i find
the right number this is
for white horse so it is application
20 0 2 5 1 7 f u
l i have had a series of emails some
from residents
and one from cpre i understand that is
the same for all of our
members so consider that um a disclosure
for all of us
uh we are here with open minds and we'll
be making a decision based on facts as
they're presented
today and councillor parry have a
disclosure cancer perry
thank you chair and good evening
everybody um i've got a couple of
disclosures i wanted to highlight
um first of all white horse inn
like yourself i've had various emails
i've also had
emails and texts from the ward member
and i also wanted to highlight that as
the portfolio holder for regulatory
services
um i have been involved to some extent
on enforcement matters regarding this
site
however i come to the committee with an
open mind and we're talking about a
planning
we're looking at planning rather than
enforcement in respect to this
particular application
and i also wanted to um highlight that
i'll be standing down from the committee
with regard to
application twenty forward slash zero
two eight five three forward slash full
in respect to morton house and wishing
well cottage at moreton
as i am the ward member and i have
registered to speak
thank you chair thank you very much
cancer perry councillor dixon
please uh thank you chairman uh as the
ward
member i am supporting the final
application tonight should we manage the
time to get there chairman
number twenty forward slash zero three
four zero
four one zero uh where i will be
supporting the
application uh so no personal
involvement at all but i will be
speaking on their behalf
lovely thank you very much and council
fleming please
thank you chairman um it's item five
the uh 100 high street bidford on haven
um i'll have to sit that particular part
out because
uh i was the planning chairman of the
parish council that objected to this in
the first instance
so from that perspective i'll have to
sit out thank you
thank you very much councillor fleming
understood and duly noted
okay um there being no further
disclosures registered um
minutes is everyone happy for me to sign
the minutes from our meeting the sixth
of january a quick wave and show of
hands on
uh the screen would be great that is
unanimous
marvelous we'll do that when we get to
it okay
um we have a minor reshuffle only a
minor reshuffle of our running order for
tonight
so um application oh sorry item number
eight which
is application twenty zero one one three
one ful
paddocks um in macabre green we have no
registered
speakers for that item so there is an
updated recommendation in the update
sheet which is to delegate to offices i
propose we move
to do exactly that could i have a second
please counselor parry
okay um i will then seek
for a vote counsellor i'll go first
councillor richards
at four thank you councillor fleming
cancer fleming four councillor kendall
keller kendall four councillor curtis
councillor curtis for councillor dixon
councillor dixon for councillor edin
council
fabius thank you very much and so
committee therefore resolves to delegate
to officers application reference 20 0
1 1 3 1 full the palette birmingham road
map of
green fabulous okay let's get stuck into
the main body of our meeting and our
first item is application twenty zero
two six one two ful that is green and
farming ships non-stop
our presenting officer is erin
weatherston aaron
over to you thank you chairman
please now check everyone can see the
presentation on the screen
certainly can
the application site lies to the eastern
edge of willington settlement which is
identified as an all of the settlement
within the council's adopted core
strategy
the site is outlined in red on the plan
and comprises of a parcel of paddock
land
just shown here vehicular access to the
site will be shared with the neighboring
property to the west
green end farm which is located just
here and the access you can see coming
down to the road to the south
public right of way ss117 crosses the
access to the application site
the approximate location of a footpath
is shown by the green dash line
following this route approximately here
planning permission is sought the
erection of a single
local market dwelling and associated
works this is a resubmission of planning
application 1903
ful which was considered by members of
planning committee in february 2020
and refused for two reasons including
the principle of the development and the
visual impact of the scheme
key changes since the last application
was considered includes the publication
of a housing needs survey for the parish
dated in august 2020
in addition the plans have been amended
slightly since the earlier scheme to
introduce a fifth bedroom above the
garage
which is facilitated through new roof
lights and an external staircase
this slide shows an aerial image of the
site for the approximate location of the
paddock
seen here close to the center of the
slide green and farm is located through
the west
just here with the access down to the
road
neighbouring properties lie to the
northwest of the site and open fields
lie to the north
and to the eastern edge the land is
relatively flat which allows for views
to be forwarded from the public realm
from the road
here and the public footpath that goes
through the site
this slide has a proposed site plan for
the new dwelling property will have an
l-shaped form and a detached garage
which is located to the west of the site
close to the public right of way which
is shown
by the green dash line on this plan
proposal will include parking and
turning areas
shown here on the drawing and private
garden lands
around the property the existing paddock
is enclosed by vegetation along the
northern boundary
and the south and the southern boundary
and to the east is a post and rail fence
close to the road
the access is shown just here joining
green and farms access
to the public highway neighbouring
properties lie to the north west of the
site and are shown on the drawing
just here in blue
this slideshare to propose floor plans
and elevations of the new dwelling
dwelling will be two-story in height
measuring approximately 8.8 meters to
the ridge
on the main ridge line the dwelling will
be finished in natural stone and red
brick under a slate roof
with coin and capping details key design
features include pitch roof
pitch roof dormer windows on the one and
a half story section shown here and here
chimneys and a canopy the main
architectural details will be facing the
road
to the east so this elevation and to the
south
dwelling will have accommodation on
ground floor so living accommodation
and at first floor five bedrooms
including the fifth just shown here
above the garage
this slide has a number of photographs
taken from the east of the site
the top two images show green and farm
just here
and here a neighboring property to the
north west of the site located here and
here
this is a paddock land and the arrow
shows the approximate location of the
new dwelling
the images along the bottom of the slide
show the existing boundary treatment to
the north
of the paddock with the neighboring
properties you can see just here
and the access andrew's lane to the
neighboring property is located to the
north west of the site
this slide shows a number of photographs
taken from the road from the south
of the application site the first here
in the top left you can see the access
arrangements with green end farm
and it's out building the second image
pans to the east
public right of rays approximately here
with the arrows showing the approximate
location of the site
an existing screening to the south of
the site with the neighboring properties
garage just here to the left of the
image
the final image just on the bottom is
planning to the east along the boundary
so you can see the road going across and
this image
bottom right is looking back towards
green end farm and the access which you
can see just here with the application
site
to the right of the image
this slide shows a number of photographs
taken from the wider street scene
top left image was taken looking in a
southwestern direction from the road
south of the site as you can see green
and farm just here to the right of the
image
the top right image was taken looking
north towards the site
from the road you can see the
approximate arrow here showing the
application site behind this hedgerow
the bottom left image was taken looking
from the road in the northeastern
direction
the application site lies to the left of
the image just over here
and the final photograph was taken from
the road to the east of the application
like
site looking in a southerly direction so
the paddock areas is the extent the
poster rail fence
of the wider paddock that then adjoins
the road you see neighboring properties
to the south of the site
there is one verbal update for this item
which is that
further representation has been received
from the parish council which have
confirmed that they're supporting the
application
no new material planning reasons have
been raised it is recommended that
planning permission be refused
the reason set out in the officer report
thank you
wonderful thank you very much aaron um
okay we'll move to our first speaker who
is
uh miss cashmore and miss blygate and do
we have our speakers here you may use
prestar and
six to unmute yourselves
hello it's sharon hello good evening is
it just
self speaking this evening i'm jane
cashmore jane hello
how are you splitting your time
um we're going to share the three
minutes between us so sharon will be
going first and then i'll follow on
okay so you've got three minutes between
the two of you um what we'll do then jen
if it's all right with you we'll give
you a 30 second warning for three
minutes is up
um and then if you stay on obviously for
questions yep that's fine i have some
submitted some slides to be shown whilst
i speak can you confirm that you can see
those please i can indeed see some
slides yeah
okay so whenever you're ready uh please
do go ahead
good evening uh some members may
remember my planning application it came
before committee a
on the 19th of february last year i
attended and spoke a lot meeting and
carefully listened to councillors
councillors voted against the
application because there was no housing
needs survey
but it was said that if a housing needs
survey were carried out
i should resubmit the application i went
away and split with the parish meeting
and with their permission
a housing needs survey was carried out
the survey evidence is the need i
propose in this application
and the planning officer is now happy
with the principle of the application
for those members who are not on
committee a and as a reminder as i'm
sure you consider many applications
i've lived at greenland farm in
willington since 2000
my husband passed away five years ago
and i'm left with three children to
bring up on my own
they're 18 16 and 14. my children and i
love living in willington and have
strong links here
but we now need to downsize and the
existing house is too costly to maintain
my late husband was deeply passionate
about the village and chair of the
parish
council for about 10 years my parents
live locally and so i can help care for
them including my father who has
dementia
i'm proposing one dwelling for myself
and my three children on my adjacent
paddock
i understand that my house would have a
legal agreement to secure its local
people
should i ever decide to move and i'm
fully supported of that i'll now hand
over to jane
i just wanted to focus on the remaining
objection which offices raised
concerning visual impact on character of
the area
this is a subjective view and not one
which i share
the site is not greenbelt not
conservation area not special landscape
area and not
aomb on the screen are a number of
photographs which show the character of
the area if the planning officer could
show these as i continue to speak please
you will note from the photographs that
there are a number of houses within
and on the edge of the village which
provide very some similar visual
arrangements to that proposed in this
application
you will see that there are clear public
views of a number of properties set back
from the highway
what is proposed is therefore not alien
to what is experienced within the
locality of the site
the site is set back approximately 50
metres from the road
it would also assimilate more readily in
my view given unlike the other nearby
and adjacent examples
it does not have a long access track in
its foreground
instead it shares access via green on
the farm and therefore keeps hard
standing to a minimum
moreover as i've noted on the submitted
photographs the council can
condition a hedgerow to be planted
alongside the eastern site boundary
in summary mrs bygate carefully listened
to members in her last application
and has taken the steps mentioned this
is a good quality design to meet a local
need
secured in perpetuity for local people
with parish and ward councillor support
no objections from neighbours and no
objections from consultees
i hope you can support the application
thank you
marvelous thank you very much okay
members do we have any questions for our
agent
or the applicant please indicate in the
chat if you do
counselor parry first please
thank you and and good evening uh both
of you
i can certainly remember this
application well um
having been part of um the planning aid
committee last year
um this is really just i think it's
probably a question to jane cashmore
i notice in the office's report
there is reference that the development
would not form
part of a continuous street scene um
i'd just be interested in your if you
could exp
in your views um because i couldn't see
a a street scene on that and i just
wondered
i'd just be interested it might be the
applicant's views on the street scene
um and where that street scene is meant
to be
if there was a street scene i just
wondered whether you might wish to
comment on that
yes thank you council parry um through
your chairman
in my view the village is quite organic
um
and it's not particular particularly
linear in in this part of
the settlement um so in terms of a
particular street scene i don't
personally consider that one exists
and i think looking at the photos which
i submitted what we're proposing
in terms of the setback and the views is
very similar to what can be seen in the
character of the area
okay lovely thank you very much um
council dixon next please
thank you chairman uh that particular
slide which we've now
got on i think it's photo number six
which i think indicates more or less a
two and a half story property
by the looks of things from what i can
see um which one is that on the
uh by my name i can't uh
is that green end farm
that property is if you go back to the
slide one you can see
um images six so it's to the
south east of the application site
that's the one now which one's uh
and the plan please erin
number six i'm with you so it's down
there i'm looking at that one thank you
very much
okay uh i don't see any more questions
for
um our agent or application or applicant
so
uh thank you both very much for your
time this evening you're probably best
served to continue watching on
the live stream thank you again
thank you thank you okay
let's uh now hear from our ward member
councillor o'donnell
council o'donnell are you there i am
indeed yeah thank you
good evening you know the drill you have
five minutes stay around for some
questions afterwards we'll give you a 30
second warning
whenever you're ready please start thank
you um good evening committee
since the previous application i can
confirm that a housing needs survey has
been carried out by warwickshire rural
community council
covering balchester and wellington
parish this was carried out in july 2020
and identified a need for one four or
five bed house
mrs bygate has kept both myself and the
parish meeting up to date with her
planning application proposal
and i can confirm that no locals have
contacted me with any concerns
our council's core strategy allows scope
for local market dwellings within or
adjacent settlements
in the district where there is an
identified need under policy
cs15 and as10
the application site lies adjacent the
settlement in proximity to other
residential properties
has a support of the parish meeting and
provides for a four bed house
with a potential fifth bedroom or office
over the garage
the proposal therefore meets the need
identified in the housing needs survey
the officer report sets out that the
principle of development is now
acceptable the office's only reason for
objection relates to encroachment into
the countryside and officers consider
visual harm would result
i would ask members of committee to
consider the following as to why
the proposal does not harm the character
of the area
the planner suggests the design size and
height is a substantial development
however its size reflects the need
identified in the housing needs survey
the height of the property is not
excessive at a maximum of approximately
8.8 metres
its massing is also broken up by lower
side projections
in a previous application on the site
that planning officer set out in his
committee report that
should the principle of development be
acceptable as part of a reserved
master's application
the layout scale height massing and
design of the properties would be
required to reflect the appearance of
the neighboring dwellings within the
immediate vicinity
if you look at the immediate vicinity
and the recent development at andrews
lane
i feel the proposed house does just that
and is in keeping with the locality
the materials are sensitive and it is an
attractive design
policy allows for local market dwellings
within or adjacent settlements
they often will be on paddock or
agricultural land
the site for the proposed dwelling is
well related to green and
farm and nearby recently built dwellings
at andrews lane
the planning officer considered the
locality of the site to be open land to
the north
east and south however as you've seen
from the photographs presented
the dwelling would be seen in the
context of the other properties
when viewed from the road to the east
green and farm lies behind and andrew's
lane properties to the site
being a rural village the area is
characterized by a number of substantial
and or prominent properties on its
fringes i'd fully expect a full soft
landscaping scheme to be a planning
condition
and this can secure appropriate
landscaping within the site
including a boundary hedgerow to define
the garden
the proposed welding is set
approximately 50 metres back from the
road
and a large expanse of grassland would
remain to its front
this is representative of the locality
the access is shared with greenland farm
and proposed parking and hard standing
has been cited to the north so would not
be visually dominant in
wide abuse i therefore think the
proposed dwelling is appropriately cited
is of scale and size to meet the
identified need
is well designed and is sympathetic to
the locality of the site and landscape
character
complying with policy cs5 and cs9
the officer report reviews other
relevant matters and concludes no harm
would arise
this applicant has done all you as a
committee have asked her this is her
third
time at committee i ask you to look
favorably
on this application and grant permission
thank you for your time
what donald thank you very much members
do we have any questions
for our ward member please if you could
indicate in the chat
if you do i'll give you a couple of
seconds
no one seems to be moving
looks like there are no questions cancer
donald thank you very much do please do
stay on while we continue to deliberate
okay members we now have uh any
questions that you might have
for our officer do you have any points
for clarification
councillor jennings first please thank
you chairman
yes i just wanted to make sure there is
no specific guidance or guidelines on
sizes specific sizes it is purely down
to us as members of the committee
as to for us to decide what we regard as
substantial or over-sized
so in terms of the assessment cs9 is a
policy we would look to it looks at
existing built form it is a matter of an
assessment so in this case officers
consider it is substantial in size
and that's where the harm's coming from
but members may weigh it up differently
in terms of
looking at the context of the site thank
you very much
uh doesn't look like there's any other
points for clarification so
let's move into our debate who would
like to kick us off
councillor perry
right hello good evening chair um
obviously this is a very comprehensive
um
application and um maybe i have the
benefit of some
other members having um heard this
previous applications by the applicant
um i think there is there are some key
things here
obviously it's got strong parish meeting
support
there are no objections at all from
members of the village um i was
interested to note
the uh comment from uh
the applicant's agent on the view of the
continuous street scene because i have
i've been wrestling with that
looking at the maps that we we've been
given because i couldn't see
a continuous street scene in in in
wellington and i do
know the village quite well um
i think also you know local needs is
very much
has to reflect uh someone who's who's
lived in the village for a long time
so we have quite clearly we have parish
council support we have ward member
support
this is the third time this uh applicant
has brought
forward an application for us um
and i can remember quite clearly at the
la on the last occasion we did recommend
a local housing needs survey be
undertaken
which has been undertaken and identifies
a need for four
or five bedrooms um
i don't believe there is this street
scene which um
is highlighted in the report and that's
not a criticism of the officers at all
but i think you know on balance it is a
finely balanced
application and i wish to propose we
support
um granting um this particular
application because there's been
uh exceptional detail done um and i
think
where we have a small village where we
have parish council support we have ward
member support
we have absolutely no objection from
anybody who lives in the village
um yes the property is of a fairly large
size but so are
most of the other properties in
wellington um
and therefore um i'm i'm very happy
on this occasion to support um and
go against the officer's recommendation
thank you chair
thank you very much okay we have a few
more speakers as well so council
jennings first please
yeah thank you chairman i think
councillor parry virtue said exactly
what i've
what i was about to say um
a five-bedroom house is going to be
substantial so he will look substantial
um they've they've had the housing needs
survey i mean all i'm doing is just
repeating it
um i'm very happy to second
second is that we we grant um
and i'll leave it at that lovely thank
you very much councillor mills next
please
thanks mr chairman yes um i mean it is a
substantial house
um i i do know that um area um
i have taken a look i mean it is going
on quite a large plot of land so i
i think could fit in quite nicely and as
everybody else said there
are no objections from world member or
parish council so um i've been inclined
to support the
um uh well unfortunately go against the
office recommendation on this mr
chairman thank you
lovely thank you very much council dixon
said he wants to second the proposal
that has already been done but council
dixon if you want to speak
now is your chance do you have something
lovely stuff thank you councillor curtis
finally please
i feel slightly ambivalent about this i
must admit and
i was just oh i'm sorry thank you chair
oh no i'm i'm not muted sorry i thought
it was um
with regard to the parish support and no
objections
i'm trying to just recall from a recent
meeting
an applicant who wanted to build as i
recall
an extension in their garden to replace
a static caravan
it seems i mean in some respects it's
different
but on on in that instance i recall
that committee did turn that application
down despite support from local
community and i
i just feel slightly uneasy that we're
not being necessarily
consistent in so
because we want to debate the item
that's in front of us not one that's
already been decided upon and whilst i
agree with a consistent approach
um many members here don't have the
benefit of your memory clearly and
and won't know the details of that
particular item the fact that it has a
caravan involved shows me it's
dramatically different from what we're
looking at now
so i wouldn't like to draw comparison in
that sense um
i think we have um councillor dixon has
put something in their chat that you can
read i'm not going to read that out
now it's not rude
but there we are um okay
uh right there's no one else's indicator
they wish to talk or speak
so we have a proposal it has been
seconded uncomfortable with the
reasonings that have been put forward to
go against the officer's recommendation
uh richard are you comfortable as with
what you've heard
and we can move to a vote um yes can i
just clarify the
reasons chairman um because it seems to
me that there's two ways that the design
issue the visual issue could fall away
obviously it's been said that that
previous refusal had a
visual reason in there from a previous
committee um
so the two ways are the first way is
that the applicant's now gone and done a
housing needs survey and that because
there's a housing need met that tips the
balance in favor of the development
even though the visual harm remains it
doesn't sound like that's what committee
are talking about what it seems to me
they're talking about is that actually
there's no harm anyway and there's no
need to tip any balance
the visual harm's fallen away is is that
a fair assessment
i think it is i'm going to ask
councillor parry as the proposer to come
back
you thank you chair my views are that
now that we have a local housing needs
of a
survey it it identifies certainly the
the need uh and therefore um
particularly with parish council support
um
i i feel this is more in line with the
as10
countryside and villages application and
whilst whilst the development is is
large because of the housing needs
survey i do feel it tips the balance
and i don't i also um
would like to point out or highlight
that i don't
feel that there is a street there isn't
a comparative street scene
in the village anyway and and that was
a concern in the report because it's
the way the villages um developed
there is not the there's a whole range
of different character
properties which are
all very different and some are very
large and i
i don't see i think it fits in very well
and i
i do not see the harm of caused by the
size or the height of the
the house so but to me it's the housing
needs survey that swings the balance of
it because it is a housing needs
um application thank you ann
richard is that you're satisfied with
that i'm taking that that
no members consider there's visual harm
there that um
you don't need to tip the balance
because there isn't visual harm in the
first place
correct okay do we need to talk about
conditions
i believe it'll be subject to 106 anyway
but do we need to talk about conditions
i would i would like to see obviously
ev points put in and consideration to
ecological bird boxes or anything like
that
and the applicant did mention a
landscape as
a soft landscaping scheme of um
i think hedges around the border of of
of the property
so obviously subject to officers
approval
okay good um officers do you need to add
anything at this point
standard uh other conditions i'm
assuming are you happy to delegate
all of the standard conditions to
officers or okay
rather than do headlines absolutely okay
lovely good i think we've got everything
covered um i'll just double check
with uh mina as our solicitor i mean are
you satisfied we can move to a vote now
i am indeed that sounds good marvellous
will do just that
in that case um so the proposal is to
grant as has been set out
uh by our members i will go first
council richards
four thank you councillor fleming
councillor fleming for councillor
kendall
councillor kendall four councillor
curtis
councillor councillor curtis four
thank you councillor dickson councillor
dixon
for thank you councillor eden
against reading four councillor jennings
councillor jennings paul councillor
mills
council mills for councillor parry
councillor parry four unanimous chairman
fabulous thank you very much um our
members uh so committee therefore
resolves to
grant application twenty zero two six
one two ful
greenland farm uh wellington in ships
and on star for the reasons
given fabulous let's move to our next
item which is
application twenty zero one six one two
very there's a hundred high street
biddeford on
avon our presenting officer is ryan
o'keefe
ryan are you there i'm i'm here
yeah thank you there we are you're on my
screen now
okay so um whenever you're ready over to
you
can everyone see my presentation
we certainly can brilliant
uh the application in front of us is a
hundred
high street in midfield on avon just
outside the
main center it's a variation of the
original
uh planning approval 180261
ful the
proposed change is in regards to the
window
on the approved and now built two-story
uh extension to the dwelling
the variation is looking to allow
a top open fan light
to this window the original approval
conditioned that all windows were
obscure glazed and fixed shut
the application site borders number one
number two chapel close number two you
can see
here and this is looking to the
left-hand side of number one
which is a bit more clear here
this is obviously the window in question
at the time of the application being
submitted
they were looking to retain
both this window to be
openable as well as this window here
which
we assessed as being unsupportable uh
owing to the positioning and neighbor
immediacy
so it's just this window on the top
left-hand side we are looking to
keep us an open hall window
this is window fully open
and that is the end of the presentation
fabulous ryan thank you very much for
that um we will move
straight to our first speaker who was
counsellor taylor from bidphone
unleavened parish council councillor
taylor hopefully you can hear me
uh if you press stand six to unmute
yourself and then hopefully we can hear
you hello yes
hello we can hear you fabulous sorry i
don't know what's happening there
no problem at all so our accounts will
tell you you've got three minutes we'll
give you a 30-second warning
but whenever you're ready do feel free
to start
well thank you very much good eve good
evening chairman and councillors um
in the report on the original
application for the two-story extension
of 100 high street as you just heard the
case officer at that time
uh actually said there is a concern
regarding loss of privacy and i'm
quoting
however the proposed side door window
has been amended to be obscure
glazed and non-opening planning
permission was granted on the basis of
this amendment
however when the extension was built the
wrong window and opening one was
installed as you could see from
photographs
instead of putting this right the
applicant has sought a planning
variation to allow an opening window
that
based on the original considerations
would clearly mean a loss of privacy to
neighbours in chapel close
after council had objected to this
variation in august 2020
as well as a revised variation in
october 2020
it was approached by the planning
officer requesting us to reconsider our
objection
because the officer had agreed this
complement compromise with the applicant
so the clerk council advised that its
standing orders prevented it from
reconsidering a decision within a period
of six months
unless there was a material difference
another application was sent for
consideration in november 2020
and again the parish council objected on
the grounds of loss of privacy
so this variation was considered three
times in total by the parish council
august october and november 2020.
councillors who visited the site
individually have concluded that having
a dorm window with an open fan light
would clearly be a loss of privacy for
the neighboring number one chapel close
as it directly overlooks the small
garden
as you could see from the plan if you
could see in the plans the builder is
only one of three windows in that room
the other two are opening windows one
facing the property's own rear garden
and one facing the front
so the need for an open window is is ah
questionable
we strongly believe that the opening
window whether or not it's kept shut by
the current owner
in addition to an opening fan light do
not guarantee privacy for the directly
overlooked neighbor
our concern is not just for the use by
current occupants of those properties
but
but but the way it's used by future
occupants
we'd also like to add that the applicant
did not attend any of the parish council
meetings where the application was
discussed whereas the labour
concerned neighboring chapel closed did
in view of the above
council trust the page council trust
that this committee will agree
that the window currently in place
should be replaced by an obscure
non-opening window as agreed in the
original permission
as the window that has been incorrectly
installed will result
result in a clear loss of privacy for
the neighbouring property
thank you very much thanks thank you
very much
indeed if you can just bear with me and
i'll see if members have any questions
for you
members could you indicate in the chat
if you have any questions
please i'll give you a few seconds to do
that
see if you're shaking heads looks like
that's a no so counsel taylor thank you
very much for your contribution this
evening you're probably best
uh place to continue to watch the live
stream from now on
but thank you very much for your
contribution thank you thank you guys
okay we'll move to our next speaker who
is miss
marie huddy are you there miss honey
you may need to press start and six to
unmute yourself i'll give you a couple
of seconds to be able to do that
hopefully we'll hear from you
hello yes good evening chairman can you
hear me
good evening we can indeed loud and
clear
so you have three minutes as well and we
will give you a 30 second warning before
your time is up and
whenever you're ready do feel free to
start
good evening chairman and counsellors
the original 2018 decision required the
normal window in the side elevation to
be both obscure glass and non-opening
this rendered objection unnecessary the
dormer window
installed is not compliant with this
decision
the window overlooks the whole rear of
my property
this adversely affects in particular the
two main reception rooms
one bedroom two patios and the whole of
the garden
the pre-application advice stated the
window does not have clear lines of
sight to neighbouring property
this is incorrect and contradictory to
the original decision
there does not appear to be any plans
which show the relation between the
domain window itself
and the rear of my property the distance
between the rear wall of my property
to the shared fence is 10.5 meters
the driveway of 100 high street is
between the side wall and the fence
and is approximately 2.5 meters wide
the total distance of 13 meters differs
to the 15 metres as mentioned in the
committee reports
the plans for 100 high street show three
windows in the bedroom
both the front and rear wall windows are
clear glazed
with fully opening windows the dorm
window in the side elevation was planned
to provide additional light only
as there are already two windows in
place there is ample ventilation and
airflow to the room
and another opening window is not
necessary
with opening windows including fan
lights everything can be seen unheard
whether it is a small aperture or not
from fan lights in my property
i can clearly see the three open sides
the view can be directly below the
window or much further
in the distance especially from the
first floor
the impact on my property is to cause
significant loss of privacy
and being overlooked as demonstrated by
photos submitted
may i respectfully request that stratfor
district council
to uphold the permissions with
conditions from the original decision
that the normal window is both obscure
glazed
and non-opening thank you for listening
marvelous thank you very much miss holly
members do you have any questions for
our objective please for our residents
no i see lots of shaking heads no
questions at all
okay in that case um holly thank you
very much for your contribution this
evening
again best place to continue to watch
the live stream from now on
uh so if you want to hang up your phone
but thank you very much again for your
contribution
thank you cheers good evening okay
um we will then move to our next speaker
who is mr
david uh fell david fell who is our
applicant uh mr fell are you there can
you hear me you may need to press star
on six to unmute your
phone hello hello good evening and
welcome um so you've got a fair idea of
how things run you actually get six
minutes this evening
and feel free to use as much or as
little as those six minutes as you like
uh we will give you a 30 second warning
nonetheless and whenever you're ready do
please feel free to start okay
hi everybody uh thank you very much for
allowing me uh
knowing the opportunity to speak the tv
uh i would like to just explain how this
is all came about
firstly we instructed an architect
obviously to design our extension
uh and we went with the design that he
proposed
halfway through the planning submission
process uh the company sees trading by
this time we had the plans approved but
we had nowhere's built drawings to issue
our builder
uh we then had to uh instruct a second
architect to complete the drawings
uh that we needed to issue to the
builder and this is where the
the the fixed window problem uh where he
actually got missed
uh between the two architects draw sets
of drawings
a builder was issued with a drawing
showing uh
showing that open your window which is
what he ordered
and he then installed i tried to explain
the error to our neighbor to try and
find a compromise but unfortunately she
wasn't prepared to listen
uh i then explained explain that the
glazer told me
that they normally screw up the openers
uh and then glaze the windows so that
so that the screws uh to prevent access
to the screws
and this is common practice in the
gladiator glazing trade
or fortunately she insisted on the frame
being taken out and replaced with a
non-opening type
as the wind is supplied and fitted costs
are short it cost me just short of a
thousand pounds i didn't want to go down
the routes of just scrapping a perfectly
good window frame
so i looked into stratford district
council's guidance on sites like the
sites of rear facing windows
and then we realized that we met all of
the criteria
to have the window as an opener so i
sought advice from stratford planning
department
who advised me to put a variation of
conditioning which is what we've done
we do feel that the parish council has
taken a biased opinion on on this matter
as we've invited them on more than one
occasion to come around and view
our property we never received any
replies from them confirming whether
they would or they wouldn't
we we then received an email to say
that our case was closed that he would
not be revisited for six months which is
which is something
our case officer had never heard of
before
i was then asked a few weeks later by
the paris council
to why i now need an opening window when
we already have windows that open
in the same room i explained due to the
nature of the construction of the dormer
window
it acted like a midi greenhouse and it
created a pocket of hot air during the
summer months and being able to open
open a smaller opener would cure this
problem hence the reason we we've asked
for a small
small opening sunlight
and also the cost implications involved
in scrapping a perfectly good winder
frame
which i thought was two valley uh valid
reasons
uh i feel the parish council have
distorted my explanation
they they replied back by saying that it
was fitted in
error and it now appears that because it
is quite large in size
it acts like a mini green age suggesting
that the winter is larger than shown on
the drawings which is not the case
the size of the winter has not changed
as you will see from the original
drawings
which which was approved the only
difference being that the openers
the window was fitted with openers by
mistake uh i find it disappointing that
the parish council have passed judgments
on the window considering that
as far as i'm aware they've never been
out and they've never viewed it from
inside by property or
or from my boundary
so i think that's all thank you very
much
thank you very much uh members do we
have any questions
for our applicants absolute parry has
one councillor
thank you chair and uh good evening sir
i just wonder
this might be a technical question for
the officers but i just wonder whether
you can
advise what height the
top fan light is from the floor
in other words if you were standing in
front of the
if you was in standing in front of this
window
how from the ground upwards i would just
find it helpful to know
what height are we talking
about are we talking from the ground
floor
or as he's standing from the bed no when
you're standing inside the room
all right okay well i actually take uh i
did take some measurements of these
and i supplied them to rhino uh o'keefe
uh
the measurements of the tables and it
was just short of 1.8 liters just under
six foot
so it's just on the six foot yeah he's
actually
it's actually above my head for me to
look out of it i would have to stand on
the stool
thank you very much mr f i've got a
question
for you if i may when you uh let's say
we were minded to grant this evening
and you were to fix the uh the right
hand pain as you're looking out of the
window
how are you going to do that i think you
alluded to removing the glazing and then
screwing
in the frame and then reglazing is that
right uh well basically that's the the
glazer told me that was a common
practice what they do is they just
basically remove the double glaze units
they then fix it with with screws and
also silicon
on the on the inside of the unit so it
can't be reopened
and then basically the glassy number
basically bd all back up
and that's what you'd be doing in this
instance uh well
i wouldn't personally do it i'd get the
glaze it's good with the glazer it's got
two more windows to fit at the front of
the property so i'd just get it while he
was there
to actually do that because i wouldn't
probably break the glass
i didn't mean you personally i meant you
as a but there we are well done
all right okay yeah yeah you're welcome
to do it yourself of course but
okay thank you very much for that it
looks like we've got no more questions
from our members so mr phil thank you
very much for your contribution this
evening
again if you want to continue to watch
on the live stream you're probably the
best place to do that but thank you okay
thank you
thank you bye bye um okay um our final
speaker for this item is councillor
pemberton who has been sat patiently
waiting councillor pemberton
um welcome good evening
you're no longer on my screen but i'm
sure you will be momentarily
um so casper hampton you know the the
drill five minutes we'll give you a
30-second warning
use as much of a little time as you like
whenever you're ready over to you
thank you very much chairman members of
the committee um
members this application was originally
heard
sorry was originally considered back in
2018
at the time the application was made the
case officer
identified that there was a balance of
harm
in relation to the neighbor's amenity
by the propose the original proposal for
the
opening windows on the extension the
officer quite correctly sought to narrow
the issues through
negotiation and compromise and in so
doing came up with a solution
with a fixed window solution that
addressed the
applicant's needs met planning policy
and also took account of the
neighboring amenity for mrs hulley
and on that basis uh as the neighbor mrs
hulley and the parish council
were in a position where they felt they
were happy to
remove their objections
the applicant has made an application to
vary
and the officer in this case ryan
o'keefe
has quite legitimately come to a
different professional assessment
of the balance of harm in terms of the
loss of the
neighbors amenity by the top opening fan
light being
permissioned members you are faced with
two conflicting professional planner
opinions
on the basis of the balance of harm to
the
neighbors amenity i would ask
members and i would suggest to members
that it is entirely legitimate
for members of this committee to have
regard to both
planning officers views and
recommendations
but to actually come down on the side of
the
original officer's recommendation
where planning permission was granted
with a fixed window
solution that seems to me to have struck
the correct balance between the needs of
the applicant
and the needs of the objector in terms
of the
impact on their immunity it is for
members to
actually come to a decision between two
professional opinions
i would ask and the parish council would
ask and the objector would ask
that you can there is no additional
new planning reason to move from the
original decision
i respect the officer's uh assessment of
the
the the circumstances now but i do
believe that this is a matter where you
can legitimately
accept that the original case officer's
assessment
was correct and that the planning
permission that was granted under a
delegated decision was correct
and that you should support that
original assessment
and balance of harm thank you very much
casper thank you very much indeed
members could you indicate in the chat
if you have any questions
for council please i'll give you a
couple of seconds
there's not much movement uh cancer
pemberton looks like no questions for
you but
thank you very much thank you okay
let's move to uh points clarification
for officers could you please indicate
members in the chat if
you have point for clarification well
i'll give you a couple of seconds to do
that councillor parry's first in there
councillor parry
thank you chair i would just be
interested to know
obviously the applicant has highlighted
that the fan light window is about 1.8
meters from the ground
so it's like six foot so um
they would someone would need to be
standing on a store can we have some
confirmation as
the from the officers please on the
uh measurement between the floor of this
particular room
to the fan light in addition
it would be interesting to know what the
um
aperture is of this fan light
and therefore if someone i just would
like to get a bit
more of a feel on the privacy side of
things
as to if that fan like window was open
and the the occupant decided to stand on
a stool
to see the angle of the
of the fan light how much of the
neighbors
uh garden would they be able to see
ryan you are muted at the moment just
fyi
thank you and i'm just going to share my
screen
i've just found the email from the
applicant with the
confirmation of measurements just bear
with me a second
so this was taken by the applicant um
and as he stated it's around 1.8 to the
top of
well to the bottom of the fan lights
from floor level
and i'll see why the shot of him
measuring
other person that context from floor
level
um in that room
balance your questions perry i think
i've seen some thumbs up there so i
think we're good to move forward
okay thank you very much both of you uh
councillor jennings's question please
yeah councillor paris seems to be doing
very good on a mind reading tonight
because she's
once again asked the question which i
was going to ask
but i know i'm presuming obviously from
that photo you've got to be at least six
foot two to then look
downwards because even if you are
overwhelmed if you're six foot two
and you're looking straight forward all
you're going to see is
the same height so therefore to be able
to look into the room you're going to
have to be at
six four or so standing on the
substantial chair i presume
or on your tippy toes i think we could
take from the measurement that we've
seen it's 183 to the base of that so
you'll need to be over the top of that
to be able to see it
um counseling has a question please
council dixon
thank you chairman uh brian um
i know it's not a skylight in the
roof slope as such but my understanding
from an architect i was working with
is if a skylight was fitted that was 1.7
meters from the floor
it would not need planning permission
being 1.7
i just wonder if that is a true if so
whether that has that a bearing
on tonight's considerations
if do you want me to come back on that
one ryan
please do richard if you're ready to go
yeah um
i couldn't comment on whether a window
on its own would need permission i'd
have to have a look at the case but the
important thing to remember is this
window is part of a larger development
that needed permission
it was looked at holistically and this
is varying that original permission for
an extension
which is why we're considering it today
lovely thank you thanks very much uh
councilman mills next please
thanks mr chairman um ryan um i think
there is a photograph
um of that opening light isn't there
you know it's fully open
can you can you put that up please
[Music]
right yeah that yeah
that's that suit that that's good enough
for me
thank you very much thank you marvellous
i can see no one else has indicated
a uh question for our officers so we'll
move into the
debate who would like to kick us off
don't all jump at once i can see
councillor jennings
typing so i'm going to assume councillor
jennings will start us off there he is
council jennings please
yeah thank you chairman know i can i can
see it from both sides and i can
i'm really struggling with the harm here
it seems to be
very high this window and
i do people stand on chairs to peer in
try and pair into their neighbors
gardens i don't know
possibly possibly not um
how much harm it makes again um
i'm struggling with it to go against the
officer's decision here i'd have
i'd have to come i'd have to have quite
a good reason i think or any reason
i'm sort of struggling to to go against
the officers
um assessment here um so i'll throw it
out into
to everyone else for their comments
marvelous thank you very much cancer
journeys cancer paris next on the list
please cancer parry thank you chair um
i think i mean at the heart of this
there's an element of principle isn't
there
when you you know you you have an
application it gets permission
and then you suddenly find out that it's
not
being built how it was meant to be built
um
i thought the applicant made a very good
presentation
but i think what we have to remember
here is that if this
application came forward with
obscuring and fixed windows as they are
with just an aperture opening for the
fan light
um there would be no objection to it and
i think
you know from a planning perspective
um the the distance between
this particular property
and the nearest property you know it is
within
the current restrictions so whilst i
think it's unfortunate
from the objectors point of view that
the applicant actually was trying to do
the right thing
there were situations where the builder
sadly went into administration the wrong
type of window
was um installed he then did the right
thing by contact the planning
planning department who then said you
need to submit
a um adida variation and we have what we
have
in front of us and if we looked at this
as an application that came forward from
day one
we would not be in a situation to be
objecting to it
because of the height of the fan light
and it is not normal behavior for
someone to stand on a stool
and therefore um you know if we were to
go against the officer's recommendation
this would go to to appeal um
because the uh and we wouldn't have a
leg to stand on
i don't believe but i'm not i'm not here
to make suggestions
but i think um we have to go with the
officer's recommendation
so i'm i'm happy to support um
i sympathize with the objector
but it we are where we are and as if
this came forward as a new application
i don't believe we would be objecting to
it because of
the those fixed windows um
and it's only the fan light that can
open
thank you very much is that a formal
proposal
yes it is thank you very much uh council
dixon next please
in that case gentlemen i will simply uh
second that proposal
i can't see an issue with this one at
all uh as
capital paris says people who don't
stand on stalls and chairs in order to
look out of fun lights
lovely thank you councillor mills next
please yeah i think i've said it all yes
um thank you very much counselor adam
i have a slightly different take but i
don't think i'm going to win this
argument so
uh just because people don't normally
stand on top of chairs or on their
tiptoes to look out of a window doesn't
mean to say they wouldn't
so therefore are kind of more siding
with the original
recommendation from the original officer
but i think i'm on a losing streak here
so i'll
pipe down no need to pipe down you're
more than entitled to uh to give your
view
um councillor curtis has indicated a
wish to speak now
cancer curses um yes he was really just
picking up
council of pendleton's comment i mean i
feel very ambivalent about this
um but there's no councilor pendleton
said there's no
additional new planning reason
to allow this and i don't know it
it it doesn't feel it doesn't sit easy
with me i think
uh yeah that just had really that
if there's no new planning reason to
allow
it seems strange to to permit
now thank you chad
thank you very much curtis um okay uh
i we have a proposal it has been
seconded
before we move to that i just want to
check uh with
uh our officers that we're satisfied
that um the any conditions that we've
put on i think that there's only
uh it looks like there's only two um uh
and
we'll ensure that that window is screwed
shut and will remain screwed shut and
that we will check and ensure that it is
enforced
upon um how are we gonna go about doing
that
does that just happen as a matter of
course i don't mind who answers ryan or
richard
um ordinarily we don't check we don't
have a compliance function
but it is a matter of reinforcement and
i'm sure if it wasn't done we'd soon
hear about it
from anyone who had a concern and
therefore be a matter for enforcement
okay that's good enough for me okay in
that case um
we have a proposal to grant in line with
the governor's recommendation it has
been seconded
let's move to a vote i will go first
councillor richards
four thank you councillor fleming
i'm excluded from voting yes yeah sorry
yes councillor kendall councillor
kendall four
councillor curtis i can't secure to
sustain
councillor dixon councillor dixon for
councillor edin council edin against
councillor jenning council germany's
four
councillor mills council rules for
councillor parry
councillor parry four
six four one abstention born against
chairman
marvelous thank you very much in that
case committee resolves to grant
application twenty zero one six one two
very in line with the officer's
recommendation okay let's move to our
next item
uh which is application twenty zero two
five one seven
full that is the white horse in bamboo
road in eddington
our presenting officer is louise casey
louise over to you wherever you are
good evening members i'm just going to
uh
share my screen if you bear with me
can i just check that everybody can see
that certainly can
lovely okay
so the application now before members
seeks part retrospective planning
permission for the construction of four
new dwellings in the village of
eddington
the development originally had consent
to convert the former whitehorse pub
building
on the site for residential use but this
building was unlawfully demolished
during the construction phase
as a result of this the original
planning permission was deemed to have
been lost and the applicant invited to
submit a new planning application in
order to regularize the works
the current application was therefore
submitted for consideration
the site is outlined here in red it's
located within the felder partners
special landscape area
and there are a number of public
footpaths surrounding the site which is
just shown by the green dash lines
and here we can see an aerial view of
the site uh in context to the
surrounding village
site outlined in red again and
moving on to the site layout plan on the
left is the proposed site layout plan
and on the right is the layout which was
previously approved
but it's no longer extent
so now i'll turn in some images of the
application site starting with some
views from the bamboo road
um unit one to the front of the site has
already been constructed
along with the front bundles and parking
area as you can see
in these photos we can also see in the
bottom photo number 50 bamboo road which
is set back within the side
which formula joined the white horse pub
and here are some photos from within the
site so we've got top left image showing
what remains of the white horse pub
structure
top middle image shows the exposed party
wall of number 50 bamboo road
top right is unit one at the front of
the site again bottom left is the newly
constructed detached garage building
um bottom in the middle we've got unit 5
which is largely been constructed at the
rear of the site
and finally bottom right the existing
cottage building where unit 4 is to be
positioned
so the top photo in this slide shows the
former white horse pub building as it
existed in 2016
um and beneath we can see the proposed
front elevation
of the new building which is to be
constructed in its place
so since submission of the application
officers have worked to try and
negotiate amendments to the scheme
we've got the top image on this slide
showing the front elevation of unit 3 as
it was originally submitted
and in the bottom image we can show we
we can see the amended proposed
elevation following negotiations to try
and improve the scheme
so to conclude the application site is
considered forward and the physical
compounds of vetting
is therefore acceptable in principle
slight specific issues regarding access
parking design and maintaining labour's
immunity levels are all considered
acceptable
chairman it's therefore recommended that
plan information is granted as set out
within the report and there are no
updates louise thank you very much uh
for that
and we will move straight to our first
speaker who is councillor
ruth hawksford from edington parish
council uh council of hawksford if you
could press star on six to unmute your
uh phone and then hopefully we'll be
able to hear you
good we had you briefly for a moment
then you might have muted again by
mistake sue
no no it told me i was unmuted can you
hear me now
i certainly can wonderful stuff so uh
castle oxford you've got three minutes
we'll give you a 30 second warning
before your time is up otherwise if you
want to start
uh feel free to do so thank you good
evening
the case officer states one following an
investigation by the council's
enforcement team
in early 2020 the 2016 planning
commission
was deemed to have been lost due to the
unlawful works
most notably the substantial demolition
of the white horse pub
that had been granted for conversion 2.
the orientation of the footprint is
different along with some elements of
the dwellings design
the most noticeable difference is the
window design which is a was approved to
have stone lintels
but now features brick sills and arching
detail
three substandard widths of the garages
these statements highlight points where
approved plans have blatantly been
ignored
and changed by the developer without
following due process
the office's report also states though
the parish council and a number of third
parties consider that the front facade
of the new building
should be restored to its former
appearance in order to avoid harm to the
street scene
there is no adopted policy that would
require this of the development
end of quote the planning permission of
2016 was given with the view
that it assured the facade of the
building would be preserved
plans submitted and subsequently
approved by planning our legal documents
why is a policy required how can a
planning authority
allow a building that has been illegally
demolished
to then be rebuilt to develop developers
preferred specification
the elderly occupants of number 50
bamboo road are at their wits end
as this has now been ongoing since 2016.
the side of their house is now into its
second winter covered by black plastic
due to illegal demolition of the
attached white horse building
planning have a duty of care if not a
safeguarding duty
to ensure that the well-being of an
elderly couple is taken
into account with this development we
would request that the committee find a
way
to ensure that number 50 is made
weather-tight as soon as possible
by rebuilding the gable walls the
demolished white horse should be
reinstated to reflect
the approved conversion what conditions
can be applied to any approval to ensure
compliance
we would like to stress to the committee
if it were not for the distress being
caused some of our parishioners
and the carbuncle to our lovely village
a much stronger objection would be being
lodged
our opinion is that this applicant has
only considered planning law
when it is to their advantage and
otherwise ignored and abused
we would respectfully request that fdc
thereby you as its elected
representatives have a duty of care not
only to this elderly couple
but to planning process both now and in
future
to ensure that any further approvals are
not abused
and ask that your most important
decision this evening
is how you will enforce planning law to
ensure it is not disregarded in future
thank you for listening council holster
thank you very much
for your presentation members do we have
any questions for our counselor please
please indicate in the chat if you do
i see very little movement
a couple more seconds
captain mills has a question please
cancel mills
uh good evening council um have there
been any consultations i'm i'm not sure
if i've misheard you but
has there been any consultation between
you and the planners at all
or developers i should say um
the applicant right from word go um in
2016 has never approached the parish
council or come to any of our meetings
um if and if anything
he um well i'm not going to say any more
than that because obviously it's
it's previous but no he's never made any
attempt to discuss anything with us
and and you have and you have invited
that have you
we've always we've um the process with
the planning
the parish council is is that we always
invite anyone
to come and talk about their um
applications
and we do most people do come and talk
to us yes super thank you very much
indeed thank you
thank you indeed thank you very much um
that no one else has indicated that
sorry to ask you a question counsellor
so um it leaves
me to say thank you for your
contribution your best place to continue
to watch the live stream
so you can hang up your uh your phone
now but thank you again
thank you no problem okay we'll move to
our ward member who is counselor
o'donnell
counselor donald welcome back five
minutes 30 seconds
whenever you're ready do feel free to
start
thank you chair and good evening again
committee committee we are seeking
solutions by bringing this application
before you
as you've heard from council of oxford
the timeline thus far regarding this
development
is a tragic reflection of the gaping
holes and lack of joined up legislation
between our planning
and enforcement framework it is a
toothless system
when dealing with developers who flout
the rules you know a small detail away
from plans whilst not ideal can emerge
out of necessity
but this amount of retrospective changes
has has led to irreversible damage to
the historic fabric
of eddington and its street scene now
eddington isn't a shipstand or an
elmington with numerous beautiful
historical buildings
and the white horse 170 years old held
many valued memories for locals as both
a pub and a community garden for village
activities
you will note it was a registered
community asset in 2015.
locals understood the need to convert
residential and this could have been
done
simply and sensitively once planning
permission have been granted
but not with this developer who has a
flouted planning
in this fashion and most importantly and
tragically impacted
so negatively on the lives of an elderly
couple
who are suffering every single minute
that this nonsense continues
who on this committee would accept black
plastic sheeting as the exterior to your
home
your retirement home that you've worked
so hard to provide for your golden years
who'd be happy with that outer covering
for your home because a careless
developer demolished the building your
home was attached to
and has not since put it right you would
have seen the photo i emailed
i mean who would that find who would
find that satisfactory and who more
importantly
would allow that to to continue if it
was your home
or your parents home i suggest it simply
is
not good enough the demolition of the
white horse in did not conform to was
not permitted by and
certainly is not recognized as to date
this developer has yet to engage with
either parish council
the ward member or the neighbours and i
question how moving forward we can make
the best of what is an
unacceptable situation it flies in the
face of the nppf paragraph 16 regarding
front loading engagement
cs5 isn't even on the radar as he
continues and has continued to
negatively impact upon the character and
history of bettington
and finally it most certainly in its
present state and with the developers
ability to improvise
rather than follow plans to the letter
is not respecting cs9
it is a nuisance site that has rumbled
on since before my time as a ward member
and i question why the parish council's
request to rebuild the pub
to its former appearance using salvaged
materials cannot be actioned as a
minimum
and i would strongly urge you committee
to refer to the need
for strong conditions around anything
you grant tonight because either way the
elderly neighbors
need this nightmare to end lockdown as a
pensioner is isolating enough
but this situation is downright cruel
and we as a society
and you as a committee and we as an
establishment are better than that
i want to thank louise casey for her
time today regarding conditions
and i'd ask you to look at nppf
paragraph 55 where it states that whilst
planning conditions should be kept to a
minimum
they should only be imposed when
necessary i suggest they are
relevant to planning i suggest they are
and enforceable precise
and reasonable again i suggest they are
committee you have within your gift the
ability to grant the elderly
and vulnerable neighbours the chance to
dream and to hope that their home will
be restored to its pre-development state
that they can continue with their lives
you have within your gift the ability to
control this application
with conditions to ensure this
disrespect for our planning teams and
enforcement officers does not continue
and you have within your gift the
ability to reinstate the street scene
for the wonderful community of eddington
thank you for listening
thank you thank you very much members do
we have any questions we do indeed
counselor parry first up please
thank you chair good evening council
o'donnell
i just wondered whether i'm just
struggling with
the objection that you're raising
because on one hand you're saying
and i i just would i would ask for
clarification
are you objecting to this to this um
application that would obviously um
ensure that this black sheeting or
whatever is against
adjacent to the properties of this um
the elderly couple that would be
resolved
or can you just just clarify
exactly what you're objecting to on this
application
because if you're objecting to this
application
then obviously the the the
the awful situation which um your
residents are suffering from
will will continue as is i would just
like if you could just give some
clarification on that
thank you absolutely council harry and
that was the reason that i contacted you
earlier today is that i'm urging you
because we need something to happen we
need the development to continue
i'm urging you as a committee to
condition beyond condition
on this developer because he is flouting
the rules at the moment
now you fall between two two stools you
have
the planning law and then you have
enforcement and i do think that this
this cannot carry on because he's
applied and then he flouts the rules
and so we do need the um current
situation to be made good
for the vulnerable neighbors i don't see
why it cannot be rebuilt
to appease um the the residents of
ettington so that the facade looks as it
was before with salvaged i think that's
the minimum that should be done for the
the nightmare that's been going on and
on so it's a tricky this is why i say
i'm coming before you for solutions
i'm not saying please refuse because
something has to happen on that site it
cannot carry on
but i'm just forewarning and saying you
have within your gift
to condition to really condition this
application
and i'm just suggesting that the parish
council's recommendation that the
facade should be reinstated is is a
minimum
request really so it is an odd one
because i'm not opposing
but i'm saying can you please condition
as strongly as you can within your gift
as committee members
and also then we need to flag up to
enforcement
basically they need to be camped outside
this until it's completed because it has
gone on
and on so that's the reason i brought it
to committees and i'm seeking
solutions and advice from you as a
committee as
how can we it's getting worse i i think
we've answered that question
you do of course understand that we we
can only make a decision on what's put
in front of us now we can't change
things and and come up with solutions
um councillor dixon next please
thank you chairman uh councillor
o'donnell um what would be your opinion
if
in our following your request
and we conditioned that the uh old pub
was reinstated with the facade which is
your minimum requirement would you
anticipate that the builder might
actually appeal
that condition and delay any further
work on this site by 12 months
council dixon with this developer i
couldn't possibly answer because he
hasn't gone along any any
logical form thus far so i i wouldn't
want to put my
myself in in that position and i
certainly wouldn't want to make things
worse i can see the
the scenario you're suggesting that
might happen there
um i just i think this is this is very
tricky i understand you can only find on
what's in front of you
but um i do think it's two-part isn't it
we
the community want that facade to
reinstated
but we also need to consider we have
these elderly residents who are
currently
being unnecessarily impacted in this way
so
there is a risk if you say no to this
and ask them to come back and adapt then
yes there could be the delay
i don't know please
and once again councillor parry asked
exactly what i was going to ask so i
won't waste anyone's time
marvelous thank you very much um i can
see no one else uh wishing to ask our
war member any further questions
so uh thank you very much councilor
o'donnell you're free to continue to
watch from
the comfort of your home and we will uh
deliberate now
uh members any questions for our officer
uh before we move to the debate
anything for clarification and you get
in the chat if you do
i see nothing and no one who seems to be
moving so let's move to debate who wants
to kick off the debates
[Music]
anyone like to start us off please
indicate in the chat
if anyone would like to start us off
[Music]
no one is jumping at that so it looks
like it's gonna have to oh there we go
counselor parry first of all please
counselor parry well actually sorry
chair whether there's some delay on the
chat but i've got some
questions for the for the for the
officers
really okay sorry
and i think there might be some delay in
in the chat function
um i would just like some clarification
in terms of what what conditions
can we what conditions can we place
if we were minded to grant this to
ensure
that greater scrutiny was given
and you know taking on board some of
councillor
donald's um concerns together with the
parish council
and i'm very mindful conditions have to
be
enforceable and reasonable
in terms of um planning policy
okay louise are you able to help us with
that
she may she did get cut off a minute ago
it may have happened again so if if i
can just come back
on that one then mr chairman i think
on page 36 of your agenda the two you'll
see there's 15 conditions recommended
the two key conditions i think in answer
to your question
are one and two that's approved plans
and the materials as per those approved
plans
the approved plan sets out the
parameters they're to scale they know
exactly what they've got to build and
they're enforceable
the materials as per the plans mean that
the materials have to be agreed and they
have to be appropriate
and as as are proposed on those plans
and it's those two that give the key
level of enforceability for what you see
in front of you tonight
if members were to grant it that is how
they can expect to see what is proposed
built okay thank you very much
harry does that answer your question and
did you have a follow-up
it it it does answer my question because
that's exactly what i thought
was the situation that we have no other
further powers to you know
basically keep a watch on on what's
going on because obviously anything
approved
this evening has um three years
um timeline to be developed anyway
okay um now uh members um
i'm gonna have to apologize because
there's evidently there's a delay on my
broadband i've just suddenly had a
barrage of can i split
speak question and yes so if i've missed
you i apologize i also
only have two or three videos so
obviously it's a broadband issue what
i'm going to do is go through the
speakers list and say
uh and ask if you have a question for
the officer or if you're indicating your
desire to be in the debate
if it's for the officer go ahead if it's
for debate we'll save it and then we'll
come back to you
so first of all councilman mills did you
have a question for our officer no it's
okay it's been answered thank you very
much
marvelous councillor dixon did you have
a question for our officer no it was the
start debate
okay council jennings did you have a
question for officer it's been an answer
thank you
lovely and cancer curtis was yours a
question for our officer
no debate thank you marvelous in that
case councillor dixon if you could
please begin
uh the debate for us
uh thank you chairman um i don't think
this pub was a
listed building at any time i don't
really remember
reading that anywhere in the report and
therefore
if an application had not been
originally submitted
for its conversion uh the owners could
no doubt have demolished it without any
permission
is my understanding of ownership of
property
that obviously would have been very uh
objectionable but on the other hand it
would not have been illegal i don't
think
so essentially whilst it might have been
nice to have the facade returned
i think to condition that such uh would
only
potentially delay the development of
this site
and knowing that those elderly residents
are in the property with as it were
limited weather proofing to their party
wall
and indeed supportive of this
application
but i want to propose it at this stage
i'll shall
wait to hear what other members have to
say thank you
lovely thank you very much councillor
dixon councillor jennings uh sorry
caster curtis was next
on the list um just think
going back to the um imposition of
conditions
my concern is that yes they may be
they may be enforceable in theory
but i think the committee needs to be
mindful that although
they can be enforced enforcement action
isn't always taken
it's not a statutory requirement and i
think there have been a number of
instance
incidences i'm sure we all have
experience where we have expected
enforcement to take place
and it hasn't done so i think we need to
be mindful that although we may impose
those conditions
it may not actually mean actually come
to anything
thank you okay thank you cancer curtis
so clearly we're setting the conditions
in order for us to be able to enforce on
them uh it's incumbent on uh
on the complainant and or the board
member to make sure those are followed
through properly i would leave it at
that i think
um okay counselor jennings next please
yeah then as far as the facade of the
the building goes
um whether it's stone or brick lentils i
don't think
so it's not a listed building it's not
something which we can really impose
here i think the most important thing is
that we get this
that we grant and get this building work
done as quickly as possible
so that this elderly couple um
can get back to some form of normality
if we if we we want to impose as many
conditions as we can but they have to be
reasonable
if we start imposing unreasonable
conditions
it will simply go to appeal and you know
with then three months
six months down the line it just goes
backwards and forwards
and the this building is not built
and uh this couple are suffering further
so i think
we really just need to get put as many a
sensible conditions on this
as we can and try and get them if we
could condition that would they started
on this building
um on the pub immediately um as the
the first part of their next bit of the
build that would be great but if we
can't
you know we just got to get it going so
i'd like to
um propose that we we grant
planning on this thank you very much
cancer jennings uh
councillor mills next please
thanks mr chairman yes i'm i this is not
too far from where i live and i used to
visit the pub
um but this is an absolutely it's been a
mess
for such a long time it looks hideous i
feel so sorry for the people
i can't see them um i would like to see
it
um uh reconstructed as i mean
at the moment there's the original part
still standing
only albeit small part i can't see them
actually
putting the original brick up i can't
see it happening but it's something's
got to happen i propose
yes with max that we get this moving
um as quickly as possible thank you
thank you very much councillor kendall
has indicated his desire to second
cancer kendall do you want to speak to
that before i ask our
last two speakers in oh everything's
been said just happy to second
good man thank you very much counselor
eden as indicated to speak
that's reading uh yeah thank you um
much along the lines of uh councillor
jennings and dixon
um i won't ramble on so yeah happy to go
with that
thank you very much councillor parry
last speaker uh just to confirm i agree
with the former speakers
um and will be in support of this
application
charlie good okay we've had a proposal
uh to grant in line with officer
recommendation
it has been seconded by councillor
kendall uh we will move to a vote i will
go first councillor richards
thank for councillor fleming cancer
flaming four
thank you councillor kendall councillor
kendall four
councillor curtis councillor curtis for
council dickson councillor dixon four
councillor edin councillored in four
councillor jennings council jennings for
councillor nils council mills 4
councillor parry councillor parry four
the anonymous chairman marvelous thank
you very much and so committee therefore
resolves to
grant application twenty zero two five
one seven ful
uh the white horse inn and bamboo road
attington in line with the officer's
recommendation
thank you very much everybody let's move
to our next item which is
application twenty zero two eight five
three ful as morton house and wishing
well cottage
in morton warwick our presenting officer
is louise casey
um have we as louise managed to get back
in with us now i'm sorry it dropped out
councilman councillor o'donnell was
talking and then i had other issues but
it seems to be working okay
now so fingers crossed fingers crossed
today we had a few glitches here while
you were out as well but everything's
running now so
um if you uh if you're ready whenever
you're ready please if you want to
uh bring up the uh the item and go ahead
yeah of course can i just
check that you can see the powerpoint
presentation certainly can
lovely okay
so the application now before members is
seeking planning permission for the
construction of a three-bed
self-build local market dwelling the
application site is situated within the
village of moore tomorrow a category 4
local service village
here that the site is outlined in red it
comprises garden lands associated with
the grade two listed morton house
and the site is also located in the
feldman partners special landscape area
and the village conservation area as
well as the setting of a number of
listed buildings which are shown
in red so the slide here shows an
aerial image of the site and it's just
been put in to help illustrate the
surrounding village
context moving on to the
plans uh this slide shows the existing
site layout plan as well as the proposed
site layout plan
and it's also of note that in order to
facilitate the access to the new
dwelling
the existing garage to wishing world
cottage is proposed to be demolished
with a new garage
to be constructed for that dwelling
within the application site
so here we've got the proposed floor
plans of the dwelling which would be
two stories in height with the basement
area
and here are the proposed east
and west elevations
so front and rear and here we've got the
north and south elevations
and moving on now to a 3d perspective
image which shows the rear elevation of
the dwelling that were faced out towards
the west
you can see the proposed new access
beyond that too
and now turn to some images of the
application
sites the top two images shows views in
both directions
along the main road bottom left image
shows the garage of wishing well cottage
which is to be demolished
and then in the bottom right image we've
got morton house
and then in this next slide i've got
some folks from within the site
um images on the left show the existing
tennis court which is in situ
and images on the right show the open
grounds of
morton house
so to conclude the proposal has been
found to cause harm to the conservation
area and the setting of a number of
listed buildings with insufficient
public benefit
identified to outweigh this harm in
addition the proposal would cause harm
to the character and appearance of the
wider landscape and special landscape
area so chairman it's therefore
recommended that planning permission is
refused for the reason set up within the
report
in terms of updates um a further
representation has been received today
by third party raising ecology concerns
county ecology have been made aware of
these concerns and have responded to
advice that their consultation response
and recommended condition remains valid
it was however noted that the
proportionary working method
um set out in the ecology appraisal
should be updated to address the removal
of the boundary wall
and that's it for the presentation
marvelously thank you very much
indeed okay we'll move to our first
speaker who is david mcgee
i'm listed under an objector mr mcgee if
you're there could you press start and
six to unmute your
phone and hopefully come indeed
hello good evening and and do you have
access to the photos i submitted
um i do just not myself
up now chairman thank you very much
louise we will have them on our screen
momentarily i will let you know when we
have
while uh while louise is bringing those
up just to let you know you'll have
three minutes we'll give you a 30 second
warning and if you can stay
online afterwards see if we have any
questions from
our members we do now have all photos up
in front of us
on the screen so whenever you're ready
do feel free to start
okay good um we've looked at glencoe
cottage the grade two listed
building directly adjacent to the
proposed development for the last 20
years
the new building is less than 15 meters
from our house and runs the entire
length of our garden
it will impact both our security and
privacy and we'll have to endure noise
and light spill
the development would cause great harm
to the character and appearance of the
conservation area
the multiple heritage buildings to which
it is adjacent
and its wildlife indeed the development
site is home to protected bats
great crested mutes and seven engaging
endangered bird species
the ecology report states that there are
no recorded sightings of great crested
mutes
when in fact there have been multiple
confirmed recordings within a few metres
of the site
the development is out of keeping with
the historic grain and pattern of growth
of moreton morale
to grant the application would set a
precedent not only for backland garden
development within conservation areas
but would also encourage the misuse of
local needs and self-build
to override planning policies designed
to protect heritage assets and
special landscapes the protection
enhancement are a key part of the vision
that the core strategy promotes
the proportion design of the proposed
development are completely out of
character with its surroundings
the five properties adjacent to the
development are all grade two listed
buildings
and the proposed building is nearly ten
times larger than any of its eight
nearest neighbors
the design of it the building itself
resembles a commercial building
rather than a building of character and
elegance that is required for this
location
the extensive building works require the
removal of 1500 tons of soil
from the site it will pass within inches
of
wishing well cottage which has no
foundations and has the potential to
cause
irreversible damage we also have
concerns
relating to fire safety the access does
not comply with fire regulations
and also highway safety for a previous
nearby planning application the highways
authority
raised an objection noting the proximity
to the primary school
stating vehicles would have the nose
forward between parked cars
which is of detriment to highway safety
and vehicles delivering building
materials could block the narrow road
i conclude by quoting the comments of
our ward councillor who states
the character and distinctiveness of the
village would be compromised by the
establishment of a
backland dwelling the principle of the
black backland development should not be
considered
acceptable those comments relate to a
recent planning application in wellspawn
not in the conservation area and with no
listed buildings nearby
the application has just been refused we
just asked for consistency in decision
making
and consideration for our future peace
security and privacy
marvelous mr geek mcgee thank you very
much for that members do we have
any questions for our objector if you'd
indicate in the chat
if you do we'll give it a couple of
seconds just in case it glitches again
i can't see much movement so it looks
like we are
not going to have any questions uh mr
mcgee thank you very much for your
contribution this evening if you uh want
to have your phone
you will be best placed to continue
watching live stream uh on
your computer but thank you again for
your contribution
thank you very much good evening okay
our next speaker then is
our agents jane cashmore again and uh we
have our heritage or a heritage
consultant emily taylor on the line uh
miss kashmir taylor can you hear me
yes good evening again good evening
that's jane i assume
yes it is marvelous um is emily with you
or will she be dialing in separately she
is dying separately hopefully
hopefully okay in that case uh miss
taylor if you can hear me
if you press star on six you should
unmute your phone and hopefully we'll be
able to hear you
good evening can you confirm you can
hear me is that ms taylor
yes that's correct can you hear me
certainly can fabulous we've got you
both wonderful stuff
um i'm going to assume you're going to
split your time in a similar way to an
earlier application
uh with miss taylor first then ms
cashmore so we will just give you a
30-second warning
before the three minutes is up is that
okay yeah that's perfect and there
should be some slides as well yeah
we have some slides ready to go so
whenever you're ready please do stars
good evening located in the wider
grounds of the greater listed morton
house
the site is not in the open garden but
tucked into the corner of a modified
area now used as a tennis court
the prose dwelling is restricted to this
area the development would not harm the
experience of morton house due to
screening
and it takes advantage of the terrorist
topography to ensure that moreton house
remains a dominant element
slide two please the nearby listed
costumes would not be harmed
they're setting derived from their
interrelationship with each other in the
village
their gardens and roadside position not
the open landscape beyond of a garden
moreton house whilst historically the
settlement pattern was linear it has
evolved
more recent properties it set back and
the site does not project into the open
space
the legibility of the settlement pattern
will remain defined by the list of
buildings
and the development will not detract
from this slide three please
the site cannot be experienced within
the conservation area due to the
existing dope form and screening
whilst views from the west suggested to
be affected these are seasonal and
restricted by vegetation
they also encompass a variety of built
form including modern development
and the modern rear extension of
mountain house the dwelling will be set
down in the landscape
lower than these existing buildings this
ensures it does not dominate its
surroundings
slide 4 please a conservation area is
not about no change but rather ensuring
that development is respectful to its
branding
the proposals take the opportunity to
harmonize with modern routes
through materials and design i will now
hand over to jane
as you've just heard we do not consider
that any harm
arises to heritage assets even if you
consider that it does
then please remember that it's expressly
provided for within policy that public
benefits can override that harm
i will outline five public benefits of
the development which weigh in favor in
the overall planning balance
which we feel have been underweighted in
the report
firstly a local market dwelling is
proposed
whilst there is no policy requirement to
secure the property for local market
needs
the applicants have chosen to do so and
secure the property for local people in
perpetuity
they are one of the identified needs in
the housing needs survey
this benefit for the village in
perpetuity should carry significant
positive weight in the planning balance
secondly the dwelling would be a
self-filled as the officer report says
this is a dwelling of a kind whose
delivery is a national priority
thirdly the extensive renewables
proposed including ground source heating
solar panels mechanical ventilation with
heat recovery
rain water harvesting and electric car
charge points
this is all in the context of the
council's declared climate change
emergency
fourthly the removal of the existing
garage from the setting of wishing well
cottage
and its alternative provision creates
significant highway and also heritage
benefits
fifthly the garage removal opens up
street scene views to the countryside
beyond which is the visual and heritage
benefits
although we consider no harm arises i've
set out five public benefits which in my
view outweigh the harm the planning
officer has identified
i hope you agree thank you for listening
thank you very much to you both uh
members do we have
any questions for um our agent and or
our heritage consultant
please indicate in the chat if you
do counselor mills
please first of all casa mills thanks mr
chairman um
jane could you uh it's good to hear from
you jane jane is
can you put that photograph up for me
again please
that shows the modern houses is that
from the
rear of the property or rear of the
garden that we're talking about
um so that's beyond the where the garden
area would be
it's from the public footpath um
hopefully louise might be able to bring
it up on the location plan but it's um
to the
west
so sorry so that sorry i
misunderstood it was that photograph
taken from
as it is the back garden now where the
tennis court is or from somewhere else
at the same time as you but if we're
talking about slide three
which um that's from yeah so that's from
a public footpath
which is from the west of the property
quite a long way beyond the application
site
so you can see some modern development
morton house and then the site would be
in the distance to the right
louise might be able to show it on the
location plan for you
right now that's fine that's fine thank
you thank you
okay very good uh councillor curtis next
please
uh thank you um jane i
think that near the end of your
presentation
you said something like the removal of
the garage
would create and i i couldn't quite
catch it was highways benefits or some
other benefits
could you just clarify what those
benefits would actually be
yes of course so um so i mentioned
highway and heritage benefits
in terms of the highway benefits as
you've probably seen from the photos
the existing garage serving wishing well
cottage
doesn't provide any turning space for
vehicles parked there associated with
um with wishing well cottage and as
you've probably seen from the photos
quite a lot of cars do park along the
road in this area
the proposal would remove that garage
and provide a new garage
within the site which would allow for
turning space allowing
cars for wishing well cottage plus the
proposed dwelling to come into sight
park safely turn and then so enter and
exit the highway in a forward gear so
that's a highway benefit
in terms of the heritage benefit as you
probably saw from the photo
it's quite a modern garage it's not
attractive
it's not good quality development in the
setting of a ballistic building and that
would be removed
thank you very much very clarifying
thank you lovely thank you both and
finally councillor dixon please cancel
something thank you chairman uh jane
your third bullet point
eco home um obviously we've got
normal provisions regarding water
conservation
electrical vehicle charging points etc
etc
what additionally was this home going to
provide over and above
what is our normal building requirements
so the the applicants have been heavily
involved in the design of this property
and they specifically want to create a
highly energy efficient environmentally
friendly home so my understanding is
renewables are encouraging electric car
charge points are required
obviously that's there but the
additionals are so ground source heating
pv panels which you can see on the back
of the garage mechanical ventilation
with heat recovery
and there's rain water harvesting and
there's a wall
battery backup to store the power that's
generated
um i think that's a summary but i'm not
a renewable expert i'll be honest but
that that's what's proposed
thank you jane marvelous thank you very
much i can see no one else indicating
they decide to
uh to ask you any questions at the
moment so uh it leaves me to thank you
both
for your contributions this evening if
you want to continue to watch on the
online
stream or the live stream you'll be
blessed best place to do that but thank
you for your contribution
thank you very much thank you um okay
we'll move to our final speak of this
item has councillor parry
councillor parry you know the drill it's
five minutes with a 30-second warning
questions afterwards whenever you're
ready fire away
thank you chair and firstly the reason
for supporting this application
was to give a fair hearing to these
proposals
and the parish council was keen for the
planning committee to be making the
decision in this respect
as there were objections from two
village households
parish council councillors felt that it
would not be appropriate to support the
application
irrespective of the local needs focus
and so filed a response of no objection
it is noted that there are three
different households objecting to this
application
one of whom doesn't live in the village
but in ashorn
there is also support from the residents
at wishing well cottage
and a comment of no objection registered
by the immediate neighbour to morton
house
so this is a finely balanced application
i can confirm that myself and members of
the parish council have visited both the
applicant site
and the site of the main objector in
order to be fully inclusive
during the visit to glencoe cottage it
was noted there are no
unobscured windows which directly
overlook the site
however due to the size of the proposed
three-bedroom dwelling
it was evident that the occupants would
lose
their unrestricted country-wide
countryside views
from their garden which we all we which
we all recognize in terms of the high
personal value
to the occupants but unfortunately loss
of view
is not a planning reason for objection
morton moral is a category 4 local
service village
in which a minimum of 32 new dwellings
should be accommodated during the
planned period
of 2011-2031 date
less than 10 properties have either been
built or currently have planning
permission granted
which highlights a shortfall the
applicants have been residents in the
village for over 40 years
and their site falls within the built-up
area boundary
and is in response to the local housing
needs survey
undertaken in march 2020 which
highlighted the need for the
three-bedroom dwellings
the site falls within the physical
confines of morton morrill
and therefore satisfies both cs15
and as-10 policies in addition there is
no objection from warwickshire highways
regarding the new axis
the key issue for the key for the case
officer's conclusion
is the impact on the grade two listed
morton house
and nearby listed cottages however it is
noted in the conservation officer's
report
that will that there would be some
benefit to the immediate setting of
witching well cottage
by removing the large modern garage
although the report goes on to say this
would be offset by the impacts of the
new developments to the rear
however the removal of the modern garage
would open up hidden countryside views
in the centre of the village
and provide additional garaging and
parking for fishing well cottage
whilst the frontage of morton house is
unaffected by the proposed new
development
the rear of the property can be seen
from the public footpath
set on much lower ground some 200 yards
away
behind a mature hedgerow and trees so
it's a matter of assessing the level of
harm
that would be caused to the designated
heritage assets
and i therefore leave it up to committee
members to consider
that level of harm and whether this
outweighs the proposal
for a new dwelling in the village thank
you
mr barry thank you very much for that
members do we have any questions for our
award member please indicate in the chat
if you do i'll give you a
couple of seconds to do so
although i sense there's no one moving
so there may not be any questions ah
council jennings
please cancel journeys
thanks chairman um i have any other
houses being built
back um away from the road
um in the village
not to my knowledge um matt
um but obviously the current development
is enclosed within the built-up area
boundary
and have they identified any areas for
the
the missing 20 odd houses
uh there are three sites
that are currently included in the site
allocation plan
one is further down in the village um
and then there are two
sites down brook lane which sort of runs
down not
far from morton house but but further
down brook lane
and right on the outskirts
of the village but but going going back
that way
but there has been quite a bit of
development
um to morton manor um
which is kind of in line with the
proposed
new development thank you very much
okay there are no other members
indicating a desire to
uh to ask you a question at the moment
counselor so thank you
very much for uh for your speech
obviously you can stay on
and continue to watch us deliberate as
we go through okay
we will move to questions for our
officer uh
could you please indicate members in the
chat if you have a question
uh to louise about this item
i will give you a couple of seconds in
which to type
looks like that's a no hopefully
someone's already typed a desire to
speak
for debate counselor jennings come in
now please council jennings
yes sorry that was it was going to be a
question that's fine
um yeah it was just about uh
the harm to the heritage assets
um and the sort of architecture
in if this had been a um
a victorian looking house or
a tudor-ish looking house would
would this be more acceptable
thank you for the question um whilst the
design has been
um picked upon in the report and
mentioned the refusal reason
the main concern really is the the
development of currently undeveloped
land to the rear of the grade two listed
buildings
and the harm that would occur through
introducing
a new dwelling in this area which would
effectively divorce
the cottages along the high street from
the open countryside which contribute to
their setting
along with the setting of the listed
buildings such as glencoe cottage
um so so yeah it's not just the design
it is the sighting of the development in
this location you can see from the
aerial imagery i've got here
that specifically to the left hand side
of the main road the development is
you know very shallow plots um
close knit there's no other examples of
development extending this far out into
the countryside
so it would be the harm that would occur
through like i said the introduction of
this development
in this area so answer the question
thank you very much lovely well done
thank you very much okay
uh councillor curtis you indicated you
wish to speak is that in the debate
uh yes are we in the debate yeah i'm
sorry i think we can move into the
debate now yes
it's a relatively minor point but um
councillor parry
who i see seems to be very neutral on
this in venice um
talk about the removal of the garage the
garage would open up countryside views
as being an advantage but it's also been
said
that this house would block views
from the adjoining properties so i'm i'm
not quite sure
how those two sit beside each other if
the the those houses are going to have
their views the open countries i've
blocked
i'm not sure you'll be able to see those
views by removing the carriage from the
road
okay thank you for that um councillor
mills is next to registered speaker
councillor
yes yeah thanks mr sir um yes i know
this
um this site quite well um
i know where the garbage is um
to be honest mr chairman i i can't see
anything pleasing about this
it's on undeveloped land the
building itself it doesn't fit in um
it's just
there isn't anything else developed
along there um
i just can't see anything pleasing about
it mr chairman thank you
is that um a uh proposal to refuse in
line with the officer's recommendation
yes
yes i think i could mr chairman thank
you good man thank you very much
councillor jennings next please
my view is slightly different i actually
um i don't have a problem with modern
design at all i think it
fits in very well with um
old designs i don't like fake victorian
fake tudor
fake 50s fake 70s you know if you're
building a house
make it is it's a modern house um
i like i love modern architecture and i
think it can blend in
and fit in with old
older buildings very well there's
just got to watch grand designs and you
see how you can incorporate
a modern building into a castle so
and it just takes a bit of imagination
and i
i like this um so
there's my those are my initial thoughts
at the moment
i mean but i appreciate it's not all
design it's it's the sitting
so i'm i'm deliberating
okay thank you very much council
jennings councillor dixon next please
uh thank you chairman i will uh second
council of mills is proposal to uh
to refuse this one it is backland
development
um there is a place uh as for councillor
jennings for
the modern development and modern
architecture uh but it's not
in this location to my mind in any way
shape or form so thank you
all right thank you very much council
dixon that was to the point uh counselor
edin next
please thank you chair um
yeah i i i kind of sit on the fence a
little bit
um like counselor parry in as much as i
think the design of it's beautiful
but i do have to come down i think on
the side of um
councillor mills his original proposal
in terms of where it is
just isn't quite right for me so i'm
very much in line with the officer's
report i think
marvelous thank you very much i can see
councillor curtis's desire to second
councilor mills proposal that has
already been done but cancer curses if
you want to speak
further you're welcome to don't feel
obliged
was that a no no thank you jay yes
that's enough
uh okay i think everyone's pretty much
covered the points we need to cover so
far so
uh we do have a proposal uh from cancer
mills to refuse in line with the
officer's recommendation that has been
seconded by councillor
dixon and for exactly the reasons that
they've expressed i should go first and
say councillor richards four
thank you councillor fleming councillor
fleming for
cue counselor kendall councillor kendall
four
councillor curtis councillor curtis for
cue councillor dixon councillor dixon
for
councillor eddon kent soren iv
councillor jennings councillor
against jim lovely thank you very much
and so committee therefore resolves to
refuse application
twenty zero two eight five three ful
that is morse house and wishing well
cost in more moral
uh in line with the officer's
recommendation
okay let's move to our final uh
application of the evening
uh which is uh 20 03510 ful at his olive
cottage
in hockley heath our presenting officer
is sarah mcpherson sarah are you there
i am check and you hear me and see my
presentation i can hear you and i can
see your presentation whenever you're
ready do feel free to go
perfect this application is for
dismantling and reconstruction of gate
pillars and replacement of gate to
create a vehicular entrance
the installation of a detached garage
the site is identified here by the black
dot
outside of hockley heath
the red line here indicates the site you
can see that the host dwelling is grade
2 listed
the pink line shows the boundary with
warwick and the green lines of footpaths
the site is located within the west
midlands green belt
this proposed site plan shows the
layouts of the proposed new garage and
widened access
way the driveway does not need planning
permission
members will recall this application
from the committee on the second
of 2nd of december sorry which was
broadly the same
except that the previous application
also included a greenhouse which has now
been omitted
[Music]
this plan shows the elevations from the
road proposed above and existing below
this plan shows the proposed garage
this plan shows the proposed gates which
would
reconstruct the existing brick piers
these photos show the garden from
various angles
and this photo shows the existing
parking situation and street frontage
officers consider that the new
outbuilding would not fall within any of
the exceptions to permit new buildings
in the green belt
and is therefore considered to be
inappropriate development with no very
special circumstances to outweigh the
harm
in addition the garage in hard standing
is considered to have a detrimental
effect on the character of the open and
green landscape
by reason of scale and sighting and
there are no updates here
thank you sarah thank you very much um
we will move to our first speaker who is
uh councillor tony dixon who is speaking
on behalf of tamworth in arnold parish
council in support council addiction you
are here i can see you um
you have three minutes with a 30-second
warning go ahead whenever you're ready
uh thank you chairman
is it just me or has cancer dixon frozen
for everybody else
frozen for me as well yeah he has he's
frozen
oh dear oh dear wow
um
given councillor dixon is also speaking
uh as
ward member we probably need to try and
get him reconnected
and if we could take a minute
adjournment while we try and reconnect
councillor dixon uh if it's all possible
um could someone please place the
adjournment sign on
the screen for us please
marvelous so we'll take a couple of
minutes there while uh while we
reconnect with councillor dixon
uh and if we haven't been able to at
that point we will uh we will call in
our next speakers
just two minutes
sorry chairman can you hear me now by
any chance
antler dixon welcome back we don't know
what happened
uh you started and then you immediately
cut out
we will reconvene the meeting now i can
see members are here so
uh we will reconvene uh we'll start the
timing from scratch
and i'm assuming you're going to do the
same so three minutes we'll give you 30
second warning
when you're ready please do start thank
you
chairman i'm just trying to bring back
on my
phone the
wording of our here we are right
uh the parish council's comments there
is one additional point that i would
like to make
the only reason that the applicant needs
planning permission for the garage
is because olive cottage is a listed
building
were it not so the applicant could take
advantage of the usual permitted
development rights
the need for planning permission is to
ensure that a designated heritage asset
is
protected the district council's
conservation experts are satisfied
and it seems unfair that the officers
are raising objections on greenbelt
grounds
when ordinarily such considerations
would play no part
it is even more unfair when the green
belt concern
is at best marginal because the site is
not prominent
and flanked on the one side by a
motorway and on the other by a busy main
road the a3400 those are the parish
council's comments
thank you chairman i can't answer
questions on behalf of the parish
council
but i will obviously take them from
members after my own
five-minute spell thank you chairman
okay no problem thank you very much casa
dixon we will move then to our next
speaker in that case who is carol brandt
the applicant miss brandt
are you there you may need to press star
on six to unmute yourself
miss brandt hopefully you can hear me
star and six will unmute your keypad
or your phone hello can you hear me i
can indeed
welcome good evening um so mr front miss
brent you have three minutes uh we'll
give you a 30 second warning but
otherwise whenever you're ready
do feel free to stop we do have some
photos in front of us as well so
whenever you're ready
okay yeah thank you
all parking arrangements are dangerous
and unsightly
parking our cars within the site is the
only viable option
the planner states our proposal
significantly harm the character of the
area
we disagree how can this view be
preferable
how can safety and security not be
deemed special circumstances next slide
you can escape the double garage to
provide safer parking and storage
facilities for our class positions and
tools is inappropriate
the planning game specifiers have
already wrought that this type of double
garage on garden landing green belt is
of modded scale
therefore the effect of openness is
minimal development is not inappropriate
does not completely national guidance
and can be approved under existing
guidelines
the planner infers limited insulin
cannot introduce the bill for where
there is none
core strategy 10c states subject to it
not having a materially greater impact
the garage takes up less than one
percent of the whole site
so many developments allow 50 percent of
the site to be covered without buildings
the planning inspectors have already
ruled that much larger developments than
ours can be cast as limited influence
next slide the planner states the garage
must be within five metres of the
cottage
that would be detrimental to the cottage
involved the removal of established
trees and building the garage on the
slope
stratfor school strategy actually states
the word should
not must which is presumably how this
lighter gauge was approved
33 meters away from its listing property
next slide
the planner states our proposals are
detrimental to the arden's
sla yet last year selectable garages
including this one were approved under
pd and full plans within the same sla
cf-12 dmc 3 states that developments
which enhance the wider area can be
deemed appropriate
our neighbours would be delighted if our
cars were removed from the highway
it would also improve safety for all
road users
next slide no mention is made of core
strategy hc
integrating new developments into
historic assets will be encouraged to
secure their viability
also no mention is made of our
residential amenities
the building for life 12 initiative
endorsed by stratford states good design
includes external secure storage for
garden equipment and cycles within
garages or traditional ag buildings
will then have you be prepared to live
with a lawnmower in your lounge a
streamer in the dining room bikes and
bedrooms
ladders in the bathroom have you seen
off the special circumstances
next slide 30 seconds and that dismisses
about the total date show a substantial
building previously occupied the site
mtpf 1.5g allows for the partial
complete redevelopment of previously
developed lands
total deeds are legal documents which
prince along with previously developed
and address these security concerns in
accordance with cs 9 0.7
the previous application was refused
because it included a greenhouse
therefore hope you can support this
application thank you
miss brandt thank you very much for that
um you did go slightly distant towards
the end but i think i got
uh i got everything from you um if you
could bear with us when i see if members
have
any questions for you members if you
could please indicate in the chat
if you have any questions for miss brunt
mrs branson i should say
please indicate in the chat if you do
i'm not seeing much movement ah
counselor mills please council mills
thank you um good evening um
you you've shown the three cars uh
on the on the front of your um property
there
are they always parked there well
other than when we go to work
at the moment so that's your normal
parking places
our only parking spaces and they they're
all your three cars there yes yes i mean
my husband is a white carmine for yellow
and the daughter
she's got a different car now she's got
me and me oh
good stuff thank you very much indeed
thank you
thank you thank you very much i can see
no one else has indicated their desire
to ask a question so ms brandt
thank you very much for your
contribution this evening you're
probably best place to continue watching
the live stream
uh on your uh one of your devices and
you can hang up your phone now but thank
you very much for your contribution
thank you yes okay our final speaker for
this evening then is councillor
dixon who has five minutes with a
30-second warning
uh councillor dixon whenever you're
ready thank you chairman
members know that we have been here
before last time
you were supportive of an out building
to provide both story for bicycles
lawn mowers gardening kit as well as the
garage for cars
but you refused the application mostly
because members considered
a 20 foot by 10 foot greenhouse was too
large
that aspect has been removed but the
planners are still on the horns of the
dilemma
policy policy requires any new building
in the greenbelt
to either fall within a limited list of
exceptions
or to have very special circumstances
if planners conclude in their opinion
that there is no very special
circumstances
they are obliged to recommend refusal on
principle
and not consider what may be a fair
appraisal of the individual
circumstances they are fearful of
setting precedent
which is itself is something we are told
does not exist in planning terms
but even if it did how many listed
buildings in our green belt
are members aware of which have no means
of outside storage
for lawn mowers bicycles etc
the results of such a restricted
interpretation of policy
requires that they make such
recommendations as i hear before you
this evening as an example if this was
an application for a pergola
supporting roses it too would be
described as a building
and therefore inappropriate in the green
belt by definition
would have to be recommended for refusal
as being outside of policy
this is where planning committees are
empowered to exercise their judgment
and avoid the need for such cases to go
before a planning appeal inspector
this applicant has been trying for very
nearly a year to achieve
a reasonable outcome to the problems
encountered at a home
for the sole reason that the property is
a listed building
and therefore has no permitted
development rights
the only reason for this planning
legislation is to safeguard a listed
building
and for no other reason the planners do
not consider that the construction of
this garage
store has any detrimental impact upon
the listed building as such
if the property was not listed the
garage would have been built
12 or more months ago and being well
enclosed by trees etc
would have gone unnoticed having no
impact upon the openness
of the green belt the last time members
were also
trying to find planning references to
justify overturning the officer's
recommendation
i strongly suggest that you do not need
to find any such
different reasons you simply need to
give less weight to the planet's
contention
that the building harms the openness of
the green belt
the only reason the planners give is it
is contrary to the
to our sdc policy which states that any
building
in the green belt by definition will
harm the openness
members you have the right to disagree
with the assessment made by the planner
and to grant permission i strongly
suggest
that you do so thank you chairman thank
you councillor uh members do have any
questions for our ward member please
if we do please indicate in the chat i
can see at least three heads
saying no a couple of seconds for those
people i can't see
no okay marvellous in that case cancer
dixon thank you very much we will move
on to
points clarification do we have any
points for clarifying i can see
councillor parry has asked
for a question casa perry i don't know
whether that came before or after i
moved on so
if it's a question for cancer dixon fire
away if there's a question for the
officers go and go ahead and ask the
officers
sorry um chair i was a bit late in
coming to it and then i got
you know there is a delay on the system
um
councillor dixon um can you just remind
me i can remember this application
coming forward
was this within this site was there
previously um a building
in this site that that had been
demolished a while ago i seem to
remember
i just wanted confirmation or
or has there never ever been a building
within this site that was
was demolished some some time ago
something is just sort of spinning down
in my head
i can i think i can clarify for your
capsule apparently
um towards the end of mrs brandt's
presentation
she showed a plan and i think there's
probably a small
circle indicating the location of the
said building
and the building is in accordance with
the planner's report
uh was removed uh some time ago
i don't know when i don't think mrs
brandt
can be certain when that building was
demolished
however uh essentially i would guess and
it would be no more than the guest
councillor parry
um back in the 1980s uh the house which
was a tiny cottage then
was extended um and it may well be
that the uh resources of that
disused building were used to create
the potential brickwork of old uh
materials etc
and may have been incorporated into the
building the building wasn't it wasn't a
listed building then it wasn't listed
until 2000
but what i'm trying to just get my head
around the fact that there was
previously there is history
of a another building not that
far from the host dwelling
and not far from
the proposed site for this
new garage that there was indeed but
nobody can actually give a date when it
was demolished
that's fine thank you thank you very
much
okay um councillor fleming please
yeah i i remember this application quite
well and
um i think the problem last time was
eighty percent of the conversation was
directed at the greenhouse
um very little was talked about the
store and and the hard standing
and uh the greenhouse seemed to be the
thing that everybody was was tripping
over
um and saying that it shouldn't be yeah
you know permission shouldn't be given
well now that that greenhouse is gone
i think eighty percent of the argument
against this uh
this application has disappeared in one
foul swoop
and i think purely from a in in my
personal opinion
uh having three cars parked out on the
road to having them not parked there
is an improvement to the street scene
and the uh and the green belt sort of
visual sort of vistas you drive by
and the other thing as well is that this
uh this building seems to be behind a
very high and fairly dense hedge
and so again wouldn't affect the street
scene in a
in an adverse way and so from my
perspective
i would find uh great difficulty in uh
in agreeing to refuse this permission
but i'm thinking about it just as things
go at the moment thank you
lovely cancer flaming thank you very
much i'm going to assume that no members
have any points of clarification we are
now in debate
um so we will continue on that basis but
if we need to we can always ask
officers questions uh council mills next
please
yes thanks mr yeah i actually i probably
agree with anything bill says there i
mean they
they seem to have um uh the applicants
got rid of that greenhouse which is a
moment makes
the bone of contention last time around
to get rid of those cars off the front
it is a must
and it probably swell with the area so
unfortunately i will go against the
office recommendations as well mr
chairman
thank you okay thank you very much
council mills council jennings please
yeah i know i think i mentioned last
time i remember this one very well
i drive past it all the time and i know
there's a it's a terrible road hazard
where the cars are where the cars are
parked
um the big bone of contention last
last time was the greenhouse and i
remember we discussed
limited that limited infill is
acceptable in the green belt
if it's if it's limited i mean in this
case
it looks very very moderate
modest the fact that there was previous
previous building there as well
um i'm
i'm very much um
feeling that i'll be going against the
officer's decision on this one
okay thank you very much cancer parry
thank you chair i think this is a case
of common sense prevails to be quite
honest
i actually think the removal of the cars
from the frontage would actually enhance
the setting
of the grade two listed cottage
significantly
and it would also provide improved
security
um and i think you know um
i'm not sure whether we've had a
proposal we've had some people that are
happy to say that go against the
officer's
recommendation but if we haven't had a
proposal i'm happy to propose
um grant that we grant application
marvelous thank you very much i can see
lots of people seconding councillor ed
and cancer kendall councillor mills
we do of course have to make sure that
our reasons
excuse me to go against particularly
because this is a green belt site
are sound and robust um and i just want
to flush those out now
my uh suggestion and my feel would be
that um
the committee considers that uh the site
does benefit from
uh the exceptions in the uh the green
belt
uh by virtue of the fact that either
it's considered limited in phil
or uh it's considered to be a brownfield
site by virtue of the fact that there is
evidence of a previous building
on the site um if those
aren't considered to be appropriate uh
or if members are that don't consider
those to be
um uh correct then we have the other
position
of special circumstances for greenbelt
um
developments and i would suggest those
to be uh
the safety aspect highway safety by
virtue of the fact that we're bringing
cars off
the the frontage they don't have to
reverse either on or off of the highway
and also the um the safety and security
in terms of safe storage and
a place away from uh the road um those
would be
that would be my sort of uh way around
going going about things
and the other reason for um refusal was
the by virtue of its scale and sighting
would have a detrimental impact on the
character of the openness of the
landscape um again same i think the same
reasons that we've expressed or could
express for the green belt apply
casser parry are you happy with that
summation thumbs are
up both thumbs are up so i must have
done a reasonably good job i will second
that formally
um in which case um we need to now speak
to our officers and confirm a that they
have
noted down everything that i've just
said and b uh do we need to add any
conditions
or are you happy to just add the
standard conditions for the wording of
which can be agreed outside of this
meeting
that is a question to officers uh thanks
for that
chair so um with the overcoming the
green belt reason for refusal
um do i take it that you consider it
limited
infilling which is therefore considered
to have
um sorry it is limited infilling
um which is not inappropriate subject to
it not having a materially greater
impact on the openness of the greenbelt
because it is a new building where there
currently isn't one um
i think you would conclude that it does
have a materially greater impact
but that that could be overcome by the
very special circumstances
of uh reducing parking on the highway uh
safety and security as you've mentioned
yep i'm happy with that um if we can
include in that special circumstances
the fact that there is evidence of the
previous building on site i think it's
important that that is formalized
so very special circumstances that would
be highways
highway safety security and previous
building
yeah so you've got highway safety
previous uh security on the
safety and security on the site and then
the um the previous bill evidence of
previous building
okay yeah got that i'm happy with that
uh
all in um standard conditions you're
happy with
um on the previous application um
the conservation officer recommended
specific conditions
for the garage requiring elevational
drawings and large scale details of
eaves converges
doors and windows and material samples
happy with that ev points
the development would be conditioned to
be in accordance with the climate change
checklist
perfect okay in that case i think we've
got everything covered
um uh that's para you're happy
i'm happy as a second okay good let's
move to a vote councillor richards
four thank you councillor fleming
councillor flowering four thank you
councillor kendall
councillor kendall four
councillor curtis councillor curtis four
thank you councillor eden
against redding four
councillor jennings councillor jennings
for
councillor mills council mills for here
and councillor parry
councillor parry for unanimous chairman
marvelous thank you very much anne um
and members therefore have resolved to
grant application
twenty zero three five one zero ful as
olive cottage in hotly heath
for the reasons we have given uh there
being no urgent business
um i can uh thank all of our officers
all of our members and all of those that
have contributed this evening
uh for a terrific debate and discussion
thank you very much everybody
i will declare the meeting closed well
done mr chairman